[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wir auch norbert lehmann für den sport
freund von mir und das sind einige
unserer themen heute
eindeutiges votum friedrich merz soll
neuer cdu-chef werden gleich im ersten
wahlgang bolt der 66 jährige die
absolute mehrere
zweig im einzelhandel in niedersachsen
wurde die regel gekippt der bund aber
will weiter an den einschränkungen beim
einkaufen festhalten
und mit vier toren ins viertelfinale die
fußballerinnen vom vfl wolfsburg
schießen den fc chelsea aus der
champions league und ziehen als
gruppensieger in die ko runde
zum ersten mal in ihrer geschichte hat
die cdu ihre gut 400.000 mitglieder über
den neuen parteichef abstimmen lassen
fast
250.000 nutzten die gelegenheit die
meisten um friedrich merz zu wähnen der
ehemalige fraktionschef erreichte 62 1
prozent deutlich dahinter norbert
röttgen mit 25,8 prozent ex
kanzleramtschef helge braun bekam 12,1
prozent vom mitglieder votum berichtet
david guetta
als die ergebnis balken für die
öffentlichkeit nach oben fahren fällt es
friedrich merz schwer den triumph noch
zu verbergen er und die anderen
kandidaten kennen schon seit einigen
minuten dieses ergebnis
[Applaus]
haben sie die faust geballt oder was sie
gemacht
hat im stillen aber
nur ganz still zuvor hatte es zweimal
nicht wow sondernau heißen auf
parteitagen unterlag märz annegret kramp
karrenbauer ende 2018 und etwa zwei
jahre später armin laschet nun im
dritten anlauf klappt es diesmal per
mitglieder votum bei dem zwei drittel
mitgemacht haben und das noch formal auf
einem partei tag im januar bestätigt
werden muss ich werde selbstverständlich
auch für die partei in der ganzen breite
stehen und auch alle themen mit
behandeln die unsere partei als wichtig
empfindet und ich hoffe dass es mir
gelingt auch alle anderen in die führung
der partei so zu integrieren dass daraus
wird da wir wirklich wieder ein ein bild
eines ganzen wird doch merz hat ein fest
sitzendes image das er selbst zerrbild
nennt als alter merkel rivale und
kritiker als strammer konservativer und
wirtschaftsliberaler norbert röttgen
platz zwei und helge braun platz drei
hatten versucht sich als mitbewerber der
mitte abzugrenzen jetzt ist entschieden
und jetzt durch die cdu gemeinsam
kämpfen mit diesem rückenwind von zwei
drittel unserer mitglieder glaube ich
kann man wirklich sagen
ist das ein großartiges ergebnis märz
muss nun eine zuletzt auf zerstrittene
partei einen in der heute den neuen
applaus gespendet wird und manch anderen
trost
fragen mit theo koll in berlin was ist
von friedrich merz in seiner neuen rolle
zu erwarten sind zunächst einmal ist
märz der größt mögliche personelle bruch
mit der ära merkel das ist das klare
signal eines schnitts nicht nur dass
hier fast zwei drittel für märz gestimmt
haben merkels ebenfalls kandidierende
kanzleramtschef brown hat besonders
schlecht abgeschnitten von merz ist in
jedem fall klare kante zu erwarten
programmatisch und auch rhetorisch die
cdu ist durch den machtverlust und die
letzten jahre der schwierigen
vorsitzenden suche ja zutiefst
verunsichert und offensichtlich sucht
sie jetzt profil und führung und das
durch jemanden mit dem machtanspruch von
friedrich mehr als er dürfte übrigens
auch deutlich selbstbewusster und
schärfer mit der csu mit markus söder
umgehen mein tipp wäre da wird es bei
zwei alpha männern auch um die
dominantere ansage gehen und auch im
parlament muss märz die in 60
regierungsjahren ja zunehmend
vernachlässigte partei wieder als starke
opposition etablieren da könnte die luft
bald dünn werden für den nur noch bis
april gewählten fraktionsvorsitzende
ralph brinkhaus der erste große test für
märz kommt dann schon im nächsten
halbjahr mit drei landtagswahlen und da
geht es jeweils um erhalt oder verlust
von cdu-ministerpräsidenten
klare einschätzung aus berlin vielen
dank theo koll
im heute journal stellt sich friedrich
merz den fragen von claus kleber mehr
über ihn und die verlierer des ersten
mitgliederentscheid zwei zdf heute oder
in der zdf- heute- app dort gibt es auch
ein interview was die junge generation
der cdu vom künftigen 66 jährigen
vorsitzenden hält
jetzt zu corona da prognostiziert
gesundheitsminister lauterbach
schwierige zeiten wegen der neuen
omikron variante gehe er von einer
massiven fünften welle aus deutschland
müsse sich auf eine herausforderung
einstellen die wir in dieser form noch
nicht erlebt haben sagt lauterbach auch
deswegen will die bundesregierung an den
zweijährigen im einzelhandel festhalten
obwohl ein gericht in niedersachsen die
regel gestern gekippt hatte als einziges
bundesland können jetzt in niedersachsen
auch ungeimpfte wieder überall shoppen
gehen malin ihlau und fabian köhler
berichten
maske und abstand reichen aus die
zweijährige hielt in niedersachsen nur
wenige tage einzelhändler sebastian
rechenbach ist erleichtert wir spüren
schon eine deutliche belebung auch schon
am heutigen tag und rechnen einfach
damit das ist einfach auf die art und
weise des vereins geschäft besser laufen
wird das oberverwaltungsgericht lüneburg
hatte entschieden eine beschränkung im
einzelhandel auf geimpfte und genesene
sei keine notwendige infektionsschutz
maßnahme und verstoße gegen
gleichbehandlung so die richter klar ist
die entscheidung gilt ab sofort und nur
für niedersachsen aber das
oberverwaltungsgericht lüneburg
argumentiert sehr grundsätzlich es sei
nicht ausreichend belegt dass sich
menschen überhaupt in geschäften
infizieren vielmehr könne es ausreichend
sein ffp zwei masken zu tragen und diese
argumentation könnten auch andere
gerichte folgen entscheidungen in bayern
und nordrhein westfalen stehen zeitnah
an die rechtsprechung im moment nicht
einheitlich schleswig holstein erklärt
zweig im einzelhandel für rechtmäßig und
sieht darin ein wirksames mittel
gesundheitsexperten stützen dies es ist
glaube ich ein gutes signal im moment
diese regelung zu kippen denn wir sind
ja gerade auf dem weg die momentan
zirkulierende delta variante
einigermaßen in den griff zu bekommen
und es kommt auf uns eine noch deutlich
infektiöse variante die omikron variante
zu in dänemark und england breitet sich
omikron bereits massiv aus
gesundheitsminister lauterbach warnt
eindringlich auch ich gehe von einer
massiven fünfte welle auf aus ich bin
mit den kolleginnen und kollegen politik
wir aber auch wissenschaftlich in
england im engen austausch wir haben uns
gestern noch abgestimmt und die kollegen
sagen dass das was dort vor ort
beobachtet wird alles also übertrifft
was also in der gesamten pandemie bisher
beobachtet wurde
niedersachsen befürchtet nun kurz vor
dem fest dass mehr ungeimpfte zum
einkaufen ins land kommen könnten die
botschaft sollte eigentlich eine andere
seien
die neuinfektionen sinken zwar aber
nicht schnell genug sagt das robert koch
institut und zeigt sich besorgt weil die
intensivstationen immer noch voll sind
und die mikrowelle droht das lka meldet
neuinfektionen innerhalb eines tages das
sind 10.320 weniger als vor einer woche
437 menschen starben die inzidenz sinkt
weiter auf jetzt 3
131,8
bei kindern und jugendlichen liegt die
inzidenz deutlich höher um vor
weihnachten kontakte zu reduzieren
ziehen einige bundesländer die notbremse
an den schulen baden württemberg
thüringen und niedersachsen haben die
präsenzpflicht in der kommenden woche
aufgehoben in mecklenburg vorpommern ist
heute letzte unterrichtstag die kinder
bekommen aber hausaufgaben früher ferien
haben die schülerinnen und schüler in
sachsen anhalt und in brandenburg von
dort berichtet anja klingbeil
anstrengende wochen liegen hinter
schülern und lehrern am bertha von
suttner gymnasium in potsdam
präsenzunterricht mit maske und
abstandsregeln freude nun auf die
vorgezogenen ferien ich sehe es auch als
kleine belohnung für die schüler weil
wir jetzt immer acht stunden in der
schule sitzen und sowas und die zahlen
sind ja nicht nur in der bevölkerung
hoch gehören sondern auch bei den
schülern und so dass man darauf
vielleicht noch etwas entspannung
reinkriegt obwohl jede menge lehrstoff
aufgeholt werden muss hat brandenburg
wegen desinfektions geschehens bei
kindern seine schulferien um drei tage
nach vorne verlegt für virologen
fragwürdig ich finde das nicht sinnvoll
wagen und zwar wenige infektionen
vielleicht noch verhindern kann aber das
wird sich auf die epidemie nicht
maßgeblich auswirken das allerwichtigste
war eigentlich dass die kinder geben
spürten und zwar so schnell wie möglich
außerdem gibt es noch immer wenige
luftfilter auch corona tests für die
tägliche an wendungen und besseren
schutz sind mangelware die eltern
vermissen wirksame maßnahmen für einen
stabilen schulbetrieb in der pandemie
die verlängerung der weihnachtsferien
was jetzt auch gekommen ist ist keine
hilfe für eltern die müssen trotzdem
arbeiten gehen die notbetreuung die
stadt findet das da sollen sich lehrer
freiwillig melden die ordner sind
überlastet es stiftet mehr chaos als
ordnung mit blick auf die neue coruna
virusvariante omikron müsse dringend
gehandelt werden verlängerte ferien
seien keine dauerlösung
der milliardenschwere corona hilfsfonds
für größere unternehmen wird verlängert
er läuft nun bis zum 30 juni
2022 das beschloss der bundesrat die
länderkammer stimmte darüber hinaus dem
böllerverbot für silvester zu wie schon
im vorjahr darf kein feuerwerk verkauft
werden damit sollen unfälle vermieden
werden um die durch corona belasteten
krankenhäuser zu schonen
ein möglicher angriff russlands auf die
ukraine beunruhigt seit wochen die
internationale gemeinschaft nach den usa
und den g 7 haben jetzt auch die staats-
und regierungschefs beim eu-gipfel
moskau gedroht jede weitere militärische
aggression gegen die ukraine werde
massive konsequenzen und hohe kosten
nach sich ziehen florian neuhann in
brüssel diese warnung war zu erwarten
was steht dahinter
das ist die frage die man hinter
verschlossenen türen hin und her gewälzt
hat und natürlich gibt es eine reihe von
ideen das reicht von einfachen
sanktionen gegen italien aus dem umfeld
von wladimir putin bis hin zur
wahrscheinlich schärfsten waffe des
westens das wäre der ausschluss
russlands aus dem zahlungssystem swift
aber eigentlich will man diese
sanktionen öffentlichen nicht aus
buchstabieren sondern hofft dass allein
die drohung damit schon dazu führt dass
russland eben die ukraine nicht angreift
russland selbst hat heute wiederum
einige forderungen an die adresse des
westens veröffentlicht man verlangt etwa
dass die nato definitiv auf eine weitere
ost-erweiterung verzichtet und dass sie
ihre truppen aus dem baltikum abziehen
beides dinge die man hier im vorfeld
immer wieder ausgeschlossen hatte also
auch nicht erfüllen wird insofern man
zeigt sich heute zwar gesprächsbereit
sieht diesen vorschlag aber definitiv
nicht als zeichen von entspannung
dankeschön nach brüssel florian neumann
was bedeutet es für die menschen in der
ukraine wenn russland mobil macht und
die eu mit drohungen reagiert schon seit
2014 stehen im osten ihres landes die
regierungstruppen den von russland
unterstützten separatisten gegenüber der
im moment geltende waffenstillstand wird
immer wieder verletzt dazu kommt dass
russland nach einschätzung der
us-geheimdienste auf seiner seite der
grenze 70.000 soldaten zusammengezogen
hat und einen einmarsch planen könnte
christian senn bericht hat die
friedensglocke in mario pohl steht für
den glauben und die hoffnung auf frieden
die frontlinie im osten der ukraine ist
nicht weit entfernt
der krieg wird hier seit mehr als sieben
jahren zum alltag von europa erwarten
die menschen nicht viel die drohungen
aus der eu richtung russland spielen
hier keine große rolle
was ist europa ich weiß nicht was europa
ist ich wohne in der ukraine
hier ist meine heimat und auf europa
asien und amerika pfeife ich
wir wollen frieden den menschen steht
das ganze bis zum hals das zuhören an
der frontlinie haben sie ihren feind die
prorussischen separatisten immer im
blick seit russland seine truppen an der
ukrainischen grenze zusammengezogen hat
ist die lage auch hier angespannter
geraten hier nicht in panik wir bereiten
uns auf das schlimmste vor das
wichtigste ist bereit zu sein aber ob es
passiert oder nicht liegt nicht an uns
auf der russischen seite sieht man in
der nähe der grenze panzer und
militärfahrzeuge
ob nur zu übungszwecken ist nicht klar
russland bestreitet dass es
angriffspläne gibt doch die ukraine
fühlt sich bedroht
russland verschärft weiter die
sicherheitslage entlang der ukrainischen
grenze und in denen vorübergehend
besetzten gebieten im donbass und der
krim in mario pohl wollen die menschen
von krieg nichts hören und europa und
die usa finden sie sollen sich nicht
einmischen
der karlspreis geht im nächsten jahr
nach belarus an drei bürgerrechtlerinnen
die gesichter der politischen opposition
svetlana tisch an oskar maria kohl es
nie koffer und veronika sepp carlo sie
seien symbole für den geist der freiheit
so das direktorium in aachen ihr einsatz
gegen brutale staatliche willkür habe
zutiefst beeindruckt der karlspreis wird
seit 1950 für besondere verdienste um
die europäische einigung verliehen
die bundesregierung stuft frankreich
dänemark und norwegen wegen hoher corona
infektionszahlen von sonntag an als
hochrisiko gebiete ein das gab soeben
das robert koch institut bekannt wer aus
einem risikogebiet einreist und nicht
vollständig geimpft oder gewesen ist
muss für zehn tage in quarantäne und
kann sich frühestens fünf tage nach der
einreise mit einem negativen test davon
befreien
jetzt zu einem anderen krisenherd nach
äthiopien seit fast einem jahr bekämpfen
sich dort die regierung und rebellen im
norden des landes in der abtrünnigen
provinz tigray die vereinten nationen
gehen davon aus dass alle kriegsparteien
dort gräueltaten verüben und vor allem
die zivilbevölkerung darunter leidet die
humanitäre krise in dem land mit 112
millionen einwohnern werde immer
schlimmer susan von lojewski
vor einem jahr musste er nach kenia
fliehen wolle jsg prädikat ist die 3
seine familie ist noch immer dort über
umwege weiß der journalist dass sie noch
liebt die lebensbedingungen aber so sagt
er seien eine katastrophe
es gibt keine gesundheitsversorgung
keine medizin kinder bekommen nichts zu
essen wenn man sich die berichte aus den
krankenhäusern anschaut sterben jeden
tag kinder wegen unterernährung
man trischen der bürgerkrieg in
äthiopien wird täglich erbitterter
äthiopiens premier ahmed ist selbst an
die front gezogen hat seine landsleute
zu den waffen gerufen die parolen seiner
getreuen immer hasserfüllter die
banditen können nach tiger an die grenze
oder in die wüste ziehen wir werden
unsere offensive nicht stoppen bevor wir
sie alle eliminiert warum doch auch auf
der anderen werte kreischen seite
scheint kein einlenken mehr möglich
sie fühlen sich nicht mehr zur äthiopien
zugehörig sie haben sich radikalisiert
wir sehen die wahl zwischen zu hause
oder im kampf zu sterben sei fighting so
ruhen die hoffnungen auf dem druck der
internationalen gemeinschaft auch um
eine ausweitung des konfliktes zu
verhindern unsere interessen sind
humanitäre zugang die beendigung des
krieges durch durch diplomatische
gespräche und eben auch die aufarbeitung
der menschenrechtsverletzungen der
möglichen kriegsverbrechen von einem
hoffnungsträger ist der champion nun zu
einem weiteren problemfall in afrika
geworden und ein ende des konfliktes ist
nicht absehbar
jetzt sind ganz weiter sprung norbert
zur fußball-champions-league und
erfolgreichen wolfsburgerinnen ja
während die schwächelnden vfl männer
heraus sind aus der fußball champions
league stehen die starken vfl frauen im
viertelfinale der königsklasse nach dem
souveränen 4 10 0 sieg gestern abend
gegen den fc chelsea
wolfsburgs trainer toni ist roth hat gut
lachen sein schachzug die zuletzt
angeschlagene nationalspielerin svenja
huth überraschend in die startformation
zu stellen ist perfekt aufgegangen gut
trifft doppelt zur 2 0 pausenführung
nach dem wechsel ist dann tampere was
dran auch die 25 jahre alte
offensivspielerin erzielt zwei tore
durch das 4 0 gegen vorjahresfinalist
chelsea springt wolfsburg in gruppe a
noch von rang drei auf eins
[Applaus]
einiges gehen am montag werden die
viertelfinal-paarungen ausgelost
skispringerin katharina althaus feier
zum fünften mal in dieser saison einen
platz auf dem podest beim weltcup im
österreichischen ramsau sprang sie 88 95
meter weit damit landete sie auf dem
zweiten platz hinter der lokalmatadorin
maria kramer dritte wurde hannah bogotá
aus slowenien
deutscher folge auch im skeleton beim
weltcup in altenberg gab es bei den
männern platz zwei für axel jung und
platz drei für christoph heer und bei
den frauen schaffte es tina hermann
sogar ganz oben aufs podest
für die viermalige weltmeisterin ist es
der zweite sieg in dieser saison auf
ihrer lieblingsbahn macht das tina
hermann spannend am start verliert sie
im zweiten durchgang in führung liegend
viel zeit startet dann aber eine
beeindruckende aufholjagd und liegt im
ziel ganz vorne lag es einfach hier zu
fahren ich mag die bahn ich mag die
schwierigen stellen und ja das liegt mir
einfach zweiter wird italienerin magali
vor der russin katharina
das war faszinierend dankeschön das
wochenende der wirt wettermäßig ruhig
und mild die details hat gleich katja
horneffer claus kleber freut sich um
viertel vor zehn auf sie im heute
journal
und wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen noch einen schönen freitagabend
das morgen wenn sie mögen
das hat
[Musik]
guten abend zwischen dem hoch über dem
westlichen mitteleuropa und dem tief
über russland strömt die kalte luft
südostwärts und erreicht sogar die ägäis
sehr weit entfernt ist diese kalte luft
allerdings nicht und schafft daher
wahrscheinlich anfang der nächsten woche
den weg zu uns heute nacht ändert sich
wenig es bleibt meist bedeckt hin und
wieder bildet sich nebel und am
alpenrand wird es auch klar und über den
schnee flächen dort wird es sehr kalt da
sinken die temperaturen bis minus 8 grad
sonst sind es im süden so +4 bis -2 grad
im norden bleibt es bei 8 bis 3 grad
milder und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen wieder ganz ähnlich
wie heute zwischen 6 und 10 grad im
thüringer wald und am alpenrand aber
auch im südlichen baden-württemberg sind
es so ein bis fünf grad und das wetter
ändert sich wenig es bleibt meist
bedeckt hin und wieder gibt es etwas
nieseln oder sprühregen und wenn sie die
sonne sehen wollen müssen sie entweder
an den alpenrand oder hoch in die berge
zum beispiel auf den schwarzwaldhöhen da
sehen sie die sonne zum teil strahlen
und auch der vierte advent bringt uns
ganz ähnliches wetter aber dann wird es
doch von tag zu tag kälter und sonniger
damit ihnen einen schönen abend